yes over two weeks after its release I'm
finally talking about Skyrim but I will
tell you this in terms of Skyrim
gameplay hours two and a half weeks that
is lightening the elderscrolls v Skyrim
well I wasn't able to talk about Skyrim
when I was covering packs cuz the line
was just absurdly huge so you guys been
waiting for me to talk about Skyrim for
quite some time and now we get to so
Skyrim takes place a couple hundred
years after oblivion and now in Skyrim
the Dragons have awoken and now you're
you know special I don't want to tell
you how you're special but you are kind
of special and you need to take out the
Dragons now is Skyrim great to cut to
the chase yeah now I'm going to compare
this game to oblivion because oblivion
was the last Elder Scrolls game and it's
kind of like oblivion but there are a
lot of things that they improved on for
Skyrim first of all the character
creation now what I'm creating a
character I really don't usually give a
[ __ ] about what he looks like does
whatever I'm usually not going to see
him I'm probably gonna play in
first-person anyway or his face is gonna
be behind a helmet I'm never gonna see
my guy
I forgot my guy was a Dark Elf for like
20 hours 20 hours of gameplay
that's like you know 20 hours in real
life but usually in the game like this
you'll have to select a preset it's like
alright is your guy a mage is he a
warrior is he a battle mage so he's kind
of good at magic and kind of good at
fighting but never really good at either
and Skyrim is not like that you just
have your guy and whatever you want your
guy to be like if you want him to be
good at magic you use magic and he'll
level up magic lock-picking and sneaking
you want to be a thief just level up
that he'll be that which I really liked
and I was like all right for Skyrim I'm
gonna commit I'm just gonna be a mage
because if you're like me always want to
be a mage but then you find out yeah
magic is a really quick way to die cuz
you really don't have any armor and no
magic is as powerful is taking a
two-handed sword and cracking someone
over the face with it and Skyrim it is
not like that and Skyrim duty is burn
guys to the ground with your fire magic
and when you start getting into the top
tier magic yeah powerful fireballs in
this game feel and taste how powerful
fireballs should feel in every game when
a guy comes up into your face you just
shoot that dual handed fireball you
might as well take a nuke put it in the
guy's mouth and just be like it's like
that so gratifying dude and like I said
you can really build up a character and
form him around whatever you want him to
be like so you want to be a mage who
where's armor you be amazed you wear
armor oh look at that I just built up my
enchantment here
now I've enchanted all my armor with
buffs to make my magic stronger you all
die I'm telling you it's like the best
class in the entire game being magic or
be dead and the Dragons in this game are
awesome the first dragon you fight it's
kind of story based you're like alright
these things are gonna be like bosses
but it's really not like that these
dragons are just out there flying around
in Skyrim and you run across them
whenever you they find you and it's the
coolest thing ever you're just doing you
see that shadow fly right over and you
hear it just scream you're like alright
get the magic ready let's kill a dragon
like this is one I was talking to this
one chick she's feeding me a story
because that's what these characters do
I hear a dragon roar and I'm like
alright wrap up the story lady I really
got to go fight something big you see
this dragon just flying in the
background tearing up townspeople they
will kill people friend of mine was
playing it killed the blacksmith he
never saw the blacksmith again he was
now dead so they will kill characters in
towns another improvement that I felt
they made over oblivion is that in
Oblivion that characters level with you
and they just get more and more
aggressive
so the point where it's not fun anymore
you're like alright I have 105 percent
chameleons the only way I'm gonna beat
this game level up dammit why did I
level up now all the enemies are harder
they fix that in Skyrim the games a lot
more playable thus more enjoyable in
Skyrim the enemies are beatable and when
you level up and become badass you
really feel it one hit kill those guys
with your magic you're like yeah that's
called a lightning bolt now you're ash
and dust if I have any gripes in the
game that I just have a couple
technologically speaking sometimes your
guy gets stuck like you're trying to
jump over a little stone or something he
doesn't make it now your foots like
stuck in the stone you got to back up
and then jump over it again it's kind of
stupid it's like a little glitch that
they could probably fix in a patch the
other one would be there's no
multiplayer in the game the game is big
enough and the characters have enough
variety or if you want to team up with a
friend it's not like you two are playing
the same character you do get these
people that you can recruit you're like
can you come on my quest with me it was
cool at first I had this warrior chick
and I'm like yeah you're awesome and
you're kind of hot you have hot eyes
come with me and you know protect me
because I'm just I'm a mage with weak
magic at the time now I could kick her
ass but you know at the time she was an
awesome tank I was pretty sure she
couldn't die because whenever her life
got really low she just kneeled to the
ground to be like alright I submit you
know so okay they can't die yeah they
can die so be aware that is
this game enormous yeah it's huge at a
point when I was about forty hours into
the game and I explored about one-fourth
of the map I was like yeah this games
pretty enormous and there are enough
quests in this game to give it variety
and you're not gonna play through the
game the same way twice for me I like
being thematic so if I'm you know like a
mage and I'm a good guy I'm not going to
go do that one mission where you have to
beat guys with amazing to submission for
Molag Bal yeah Daedric gods are dicks I
don't really serve them it's not my
character however when I do my
playthroughs an evil vampire yeah it's
on evil [ __ ] this is the fantasy game of
fantasy games the first-person RPG of
first-person RPGs in terms of length for
Skyrim here it is I'm not saying Arkham
City is not a great game it is a great
game you already knew the eggs I already
reviewed the game but in terms of just
length the length of skyrim makes Arkham
City look about as long as portal 1 not
lying
it's like that will you drop over a
hundred hours into this game yeah you
will it's just an inevitable fact is it
as long as 500 hours I'm sure if you're
one of those people who just sniffs
every square inch of the game and does
everything it probably will be but if
you're just going through your story
line doing the quest to have to do with
you over a hundred hours easy which is
awesome you totally get your money's
worth some people would see that as the
negative they look at the game they like
it just sounds too big and daunting I
don't know if I can take that on if
you're ever put on an island in a magic
genies like alright what do you want to
entertain you for the rest of your life
just be like a computer a monitor a
power source and Skyrim please that's
all you will ever need Skyrim is awesome
tacular
so have you played Skyrim what did you
think of it what did you think of it
versus oblivion comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more